okay so let's start off first and let's
just rehearse the three basic trig
graphs and we'll do it from naught to
360
shall we so let's just take your sign
that first and you're gonna be drawing a
lot of um why do you turn to the answers
first seriously you're gonna be try a
lot of sets of axes and and rough
sketches so you might want to have a
rule there now sonics we're doing these
all from naught to 360 some of the
questions on the sheet that are miss
size came before you you'll see they've
got different domains but not
drastically different okay so why does
sine X look like how does it begin at
the origin okay good now importantly as
it starts off right zero no you're not
expected to know but you're to have a
feel for the shape what's the gradient
like at that point it's it's exactly 45
great so it's a great unit one okay so
what to be tangent to y equals x if you
were to draw that here at that point it
shouldn't be vertical so you don't want
to have like semi circles there that's a
bad idea
okay now you want to make sure every
time you cut the axis you've got that
same kind of angle and you've got a nice
gentle shape at your arm
Tony quite stationary points is what
you're called let's put on some
intercepts of what we say start at the
origin what's the range by the way or at
it range yeah negative one to one
good you've got your intercept over here
the middle of course is
good okay there goes let's move on this
cosine are you waiting for an invitation
to start drawing graphs you can start
drawing the two that's why I'm doing it
so what's the difference
zero then what's the Coast Airport in
case I say it's a compliment right as
you know it's off by 90 degrees okay so
you think this shape was removed back
then you get the same thing
okay so again for an or for 316 same
range but of course because we've been
moved over 90 degrees complement okay
all of you intercepts move over as well
so since that move 90 degrees what to
expect them to be now moderate are the
question come on you gets a 10 you I
always tell you think you should be
smart over this what are the in desserts
okay and that on that bottom of the
value or to line up with 180 all right
it's facial no more let's do 10x
okay now because tenex is just defined
as sign on college right and causes
equal to zero at these points you'd
expect sign on clothes to be undefined
wherever causes your so that's the
reason why you have those asymptotes
right at the same points that you have
the in two sets black one need at ninety
and that's why you're gonna get to lots
of the period all right sir how does the
shake oh you guys should be familiar
with this plan now
just like sine by the way it ought to be
tangent to y equals x at that point so
again it's another 45 degree angle okay
so far so good right just for the sake
of it since I asked it for the other
ones what's the range of 10 it's the
range okay what we relative Y and we
know that our shortcut way of saying
that use if you remember back to your
set notation from you rate that Y is an
element of the real numbers here okay
great no problems now what are all the
ways that we can look around with a tree
graph and I'm changing this position
changes characters this okay let's just
think about science so I'm gonna get rid
of constant and for now what's the first
thing that you might change what numbers
can we add or subtract or multiply
divide by to take this shape and alter
it just a little bit
any suggestions there's lots of answers
yeah okay so if I snap it out the front
okay
what difference is that gonna make well
if you put in say sign Nike sign line is
just one but two sine 90 is too tight
one right so that's just going to change
like Praveen said your range good okay
what else could we change about this
okay good
so how do they adjust the period if you
want you can think about it like this
right that this two is really adjusting
the Y that's right it just is just the
range okay
so therefore adjustment period which is
frequency which is a horizontal thing
I'm gonna have to muck around with this
number right okay so what difference
would it make
for instance if I snap to three how
would you describe the difference yeah
so I'm gonna get more lots of the same
graph within the same domain okay so the
way I remembered it is if that
coefficient at the front is three I'm
going to get three lots of sine in a
space where I used to have one okay
where if it was 2x and have two lots if
it was X on - I'm gonna get half a lot
right side only go this way so being
that I put a 3 here what's that going to
mean well this is not gonna be 180
anymore this is gonna be 60 degrees
because that's that's three times
smaller right in the same way this will
be 120
and since my normal domain is not the
360 I better add a few more of these on
right so you could probably draw this
one as well yeah happy so what are
interested
three-sixty okay now by the way I kind
of skip past this really creepy when we
added that too at the front that did
change the range but you can do other
things in that no rather phone right for
instance if I uh if I start a minus sign
on the front what effect would it have
on the graph how would you describe it
yeah it's flipped over right just like
if you're looking pair y equals x
squared and y equals minus x squared
you've got your happy traveler and you
sad one well this is just gonna take
everything and flip it upside down okay
all right now have that one there this
one I'm not gonna be able to do so
easily on the same graph or you could
try I suppose what if we compare it to
okay what difference is this going to
make
okay good so I'm going to have a
vertical shift yeah
now being that the range at the moment
is -2 to 2 the new range will be all of
that plus 1 right so it's going to be
minus 1 2 3 okay so yeah on there it
might help you just to make sure
everything is accurate so note down the
critical points things like say the
roots here before and move them up the
unit as well so that what you get you
know it's not just going to go in a
while it's gonna actually be quite close
to your shape
okay
I sort of got there you yeah frequently
do a better job when you've got on paper
it's surprising than how to do it when
it's be okay but you get the idea now
you will notice that I've moved
everything up okay my intercepts have
changed right that's a bit of a pain
isn't it now I didn't do we just made
this up on the spot okay so these
numbers might be really awful but how
would we work out what those numbers how
would you go about doing I'm gonna take
this here right and I want all the
places where Y which is my vertical
thing where it's equal to zero because
that's what the x-axis is right so I'm
gonna solve this equation yeah so I mean
just to start off I'm not sure how bad
these numbers are going to turn out I'm
gonna get two sine 3x be 2 minus 1 so
sine 3x is equal to negative okay so
let's do that actually because you can
think about well you can do your
quadrants that's your first angle we
might think of is a fourth third or
fourth quadrant angle that's gonna
correspond to these two guys right and a
half is gonna give you an exact value
right what is it going to be equal to
fourth quadrants sorry about what sequel
to the first quadrant it is just sine
whatever is 1/2 what angle you expecting
it's good because sine okay so in the
third and fourth quadrants what's that
going to be able to do you can think
about a couple different ways so if
you're thinking about it from 0 to 360
you can go that's gonna be 30 degrees
there so that'll be all the way around
is 210 and then your next what he is
going to be 360 minus that right this
will be 330 okay
I suppose an equivalent angle would be
minus 30 but that's not really
don't worry about so I've got these two
angles being equal to 3x right okay so
you divide through by three and you get
that does that match up does that look
like it's about right I think it looks
okay yeah now you'll notice because of
these three we've got so many repeats of
this graph right I'm going to expect
another one two three four intercepts
okay now you could rehearse this whole
process again and work out what the
other four are but there's an easier way
isn't there how did you go about the
Weaver yeah this heaps of symmetry here
or if you want to use the other funky
mode this here keeps a periodicity to
say that tip has passed so you got your
10 degree difference
each time right so I'm guessing that's
going to give me one ninety two thirty
three tens
and fifty a lot so that intercepts are
really crucial by the way so when you
get given a graph like this and it gets
changed around and you'll be expected to
find those and hopefully you'll get
lucky and their numbers would be just as
nice okay all right now I think there's
one more way that we could change this
graph any takers
good okay so we've done we've done three
changes so far we changed sorry come
back over mm-hmm we change this
coefficient right so that stretched will
change this coffee ship so that
compressed we change this constant like
which is really changing the Y you see
that it's actually y -1 and that made up
dirt up and down sorry if we change this
guy in here we're gonna change so we go
left or right this is a really important
one it's got special names in Evernote
school for tree graphs only you go
horizontally as opposed to this that's
just the horizontal shift okay but
because what you've got for a tree graph
is it's repeating we call it an our
phase shift anyway sorry how would I
change this changes for instance you
find out now watch out by the way sorry
I'll put this bracket back 3 next
suppose I put a um put a 60-degree in
there okay now watch out be really
careful okay how far maybe I should ask
this first what direction have I gone in
oh my god left or right
who hands up for left mmm hands off for
right
okay keep your hand out if you're
confident but you could get up front and
explain why by the way as a minor note
okay that's that's everything if you if
you work you're looking forward to know
whether something's right or not is
because the teacher said so okay that we
should probably don't understand what
he's where I would go to know that your
room you're right but it is to the right
okay think about an example that you
know about many well like this guy
versus this guy you know what that looks
like your hand right where's x squared
it's just there at the origin and where
is the is the intercept for that it's at
three right which is to the right okay
so that's how I remember and you can
always think it's backwards but anyway
so good we're going to the right now
he's the harder question how far am I
going okay it does look like sixty
degrees doesn't it okay but the fact
that I'm the fact that I'm working up
you know the clinics here you you should
be suspicious okay
the answer is not six degrees it's
actually 20 now why is it 20 okay it's
because I'm not actually changing the X
by 60 I'm changing 3x by 60 right so a
better way to write this would be 3
outside of X minus 20 okay now that's
changing the X you see that okay so
watch out for that no to be honest this
is getting pretty tough like I don't
expect that any of you will really see
I'm a complicated face just like this
this is they're not I don't trust what
I'm saying because I'm not
but anyway watch out for that make sure
you don't come up and even you're less
than 12 get certain by now
okay so what would happen 20 degrees to
the right yes success it's Christmas
time okay are we gonna go
so everything's gonna go that way right
so there's 90 degrees so this is gonna
go to one or something like that so
we're gonna get this kind of shape man
this is this is gonna get bad I can tell
okay this is disaster that should be on
there that's okay that's okay yeah yeah
and you get the idea okay that's a bit
anyway important thing is where my god
I've done that way and I've gone by that
amount
alright so again let's just rehearse
Saturday four kinds of change from our
original and you might want to get this
down okay if you haven't got it in some
nice structured way if you take the
original graph you slap a coefficient
out the front I'm actually going to put
that over here okay because it shows you
that I'm modifying the Y that's the
important thing so that's why it's a
compressional stretching thing right so
this is stretch so that changes your
range yes what else can we do let's stay
on the Y actually right if we go Y plus
or minus at some kind of constant
alright that's a very cool shift what
were the other two kinds of changes just
the same but with the X's instead right
so if I got y equals sign
stretch or squash depending on whether
you're dividing or multiplying okay now
because it's horizontal we have a
special name for that so that's period
or frequency right so this is changing
the frequency and the last one that we
did was if you throw something in here
some kind of angles for instance like 20
degrees okay it could be muscle - it
doesn't matter we'll just change where
you go that's all right so if I call
that safety knock that's a horizontal
shift